before we get started we want to remind
you that this is the last episode before
we take three weeks off so a three week
break opportunity for you to listen to
some older ear biscuits maybe one you
missed or your favorite one and we'll be
back on August 19th right after we get
back from our big vacation that we will
fill you in all about
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we asked the question are
we too nice hmm are we too nice
doing like too nice like the old wasn't
there
musician named too nice there was a
rapper named Dean nice
there wasn't a too nice with like a 2
and then a nice my name is Dean nice now
remember your brother on that CD I
thought there was Denise and it was it
wasn't that memorable yeah see Jacob
said there was a too nice there's also a
too nice well look up Dean nice because
the letter D the space which is a space
and then the word nice because too nice
doesn't sound like a cool name for a
musician you don't want to be too nosy -
naughty - nice oh I know Col had that CD
and I go into his room when I was going
over to your house he had it all hanging
out with you he you didn't even have a
CD player
he had a CD player man and he had like
he had rap CDs and I'd go in there and
I'd listen to him and I'd listen to
listen to him well I'd listen to him
talk about his CDs and may occasionally
he'd play them he had much better music
taste than you did well he was I think
he also was oh it's the older brother
sent your older brother yeah so I
technically had access to his library I
knew it was all good being yeah been
down to me you couldn't play it though
because you didn't have a CD player I
eventually had a CD player of course
eventually you did but I had a tape
player for a long time that there was a
weird moment when he transitioned to CDs
where I was a little bit less in the
dark you know but also we had thin walls
in the house and I am we shared a wall
so I kind of listened to like muffled
dee-nice
yeah did you ever talk to her through
the wall I
I never I know that's not what we're
talking about but we're talking about it
this is relates to my my dream dream
that I'm gonna I had to tell you the
dream I had that you were in alright so
we're gonna talk about are we to nice it
is a question that we've asked her I
don't talk to other many times or the
first year dream I Gayle dit him through
the wall in vice versa
shut up that kind of thing you know
that's ironic but there was no like
prison sort of like communication
between the two walls and the reason I
say prison is because that's what my
dream was about and I believe and my
wife pointed this out when I told her
about this dream she said the reason you
dream this is because of that question
that we got in the live L Tet at VidCon
where the question was who would survive
better in prison and your answer was not
me I just said I don't think link EP
would do to imprison prison I didn't
know what you meant by that I think most
people do that wasn't very nice
yeah I'm not too nice man I'm D nice
[Laughter]
okay so I had a dream that you were in
prison and you were in prison for murder
oh crap I knew no details all I knew is
that you had been falsely accused oh
good and I don't know if it's because I
just knew in your character so well that
you're not capable of murder but I just
think that the pretense don't think
linky booth capable of murder the
pretense and the dream was that I was
going to talk to you about how we were
going to get you out legally not break
you out but I was gonna I was like it's
a false accusation so for some reason
the prison was in Keith Hills so the
golf course the gated neighborhood slash
golf course that was next to where you
we both grew up in Buies Creek that were
going to next week that we're going to
visit and so all this is on your mind
maybe there is a I know they expanded
the golf course I I have not heard that
they added a
well golfers gonna be very very
disorderly sometimes they break clubs
and stuff would be nice to have a
detention center for them so you are on
your way to the prison which was in the
golf course I've got no I was at the
prison I was at the prison and the
prison was near the river the prison was
basically where we're going to be next
week
like in that area like where senator
Morgan's old house was okay and so I I
go and my mission is to talk to you
about like dude we've got to get a
lawyer like we need like we need to
engage we have to try to fight this and
you were completely like disengaged it
was like it settled in you were
completely settled in you were like I
see I do well in prison well Friday how
you do well in golf prison you do well
in golf prison but did it did it have
golf course a coachman no it was it
wasn't like a it was like I'm it well
I'll explain it it was almost like it
was just a building maybe with a gate
low security looked like a medium to low
security prison okay for murder and who
did I kill I don't have the details of
the murder I'd like they didn't register
with me I just knew that you were
innocent and I was like I got to talk to
link about this but when I began talking
about it again like you were like not
responsive to the idea of like
challenging this it was I dejected or
was I happy
what was my state and you were
indifferent you were disengaged and I
was very mad that's very upset with you
yeah cuz I did want to get into also
your emotional state because I think
this could be revealing so before I made
you angry
what was your emotional state were you
crying were you the beginning of the
dream at least as far as I remember was
I am at Gulf prison and I've got I've
got to figure this out I got to get link
out of here he was just very much just
that was it and I'm like I'm going there
start talking to you in like the area
where you can talk to prisoners you've
got on you have on an orange
shirt was there an orange jumpsuit no
I'm was their last sitting at a table
with you okay
and but no touching and I was like hey
man like you didn't do this like we got
to get your story out there and you and
you just weren't saying anything you
were kind of just like looking at me
like why are you so upset about this so
then the door opens oh and I'm like this
is it just like the door to the room
opens and there's a hardened to the door
opens and there's just woods yeah not a
well-designed prison like the door opens
and we can totally get out was there
like music and a special light like that
doesn't happen in my dreams so I looked
at you and I was like let's go because I
was what was happening in my brain was
we got to go through this long legal
procedure to get him out he's not even
on board were you thinking about content
we think about our careers the weirdest
thing about our friendship oh yeah I
really need to know I can make up an
answer nobody I feel a certain way no
I'm saying I don't know I well it's a
dream I'm it's frights of fragmented
reality you know what I'm saying
probably all wrapped up together so I
was probably thinking like prison
content the funny thing is is as you you
did it took you a second to be like okay
I'm gonna go but you you ran out after
me and my old Dodge Intrepid that I
drove at the end of high school in the
beginning of college was the car that I
was driving because that's how these
things happen in dreams mm-hmm and I and
I just get into the trap and start
driving and you are running after the
intrepid like it's a turrent like
catching a train so in other words I'm
running away without the guy that I'm
trying to get out of prison it's like
where am I going
I just visited prison I don't have to
leave in a hurry it seemed that it was I
had a motivation issue so you really
needed to they needed to get me off the
dive in you're running next to the car
and then I'm like get into the car and
you're like but my shirt is messed up
what and I look in the sleeves of your
orange jumpsuit are detached in like
you've taped them all
and you're like trying to get the tape
right that's important get it can't get
into a getaway vehicle and up my sleeves
are not perfect hi Ron eclis would have
been better to like shed the jumpsuit
you don't want to be driving around town
and like a in an intrepid with a with a
prison uniform on see did it have like
golf insignia is there anything on no
golf relation hmm there's nothing
related to go did I get in you got in we
start driving down that part of the
circle and Keith hills and we're driving
like towards Wiggins old house like
coming around that way the big house and
well I guess prisons the big house but
he had a large and apparently the
security response is incredibly quick
because literally we've been out of
prison for 17 seconds and there's
already cops with teams of dogs Wow like
commie cops with teams of dogs coming
through the yards along the all the
houses right there on the river coming
out of the wood we just drive by them
slow yeah I wouldn't want to draw any
just keep it cool I wanted to make sure
they saw your your are initially he was
yeah so my sleeves are intact well
they're taped a little bit
that doesn't seem suspicious and as is
the case with a lot of dreams that reach
a real point of excitement like that I
woke up at that well about then the
weirdest thing happened now this was
Saturday night I ended up staying
Saturday night because locking it ended
up having some games in Anaheim
basketball games so I was like oh I'm
already got the hotel room let's stay it
VidCon for another day and I so this
dream woke me up at about 5 o'clock in
the morning mm-hmm now I had every
reason an intention to go back to sleep
but the thing that I could not stop
thinking about is how to get away from
the cops while you're awake I was awake
and I was literally I was trying to go
back to sleep at night and now as I
would go back to sleep the thing that I
would almost begin dreaming about was
picking up the chase where it left off
and what I was gonna do like a
choose-your-own-adventure and I went
through all these things
I was like well they're definitely like
try trying to drive out there's only one
way out of the gate like there's no
they're gonna have the gate barricaded
like we can't get out so what we should
have done is we should have gone down to
the river and I was like should we have
crossed the river no because they would
find us they've got helicopters and
stuff and I was like know what we should
have done is we should have waited until
it was night and then we should have
gotten into a canoe and gone way down
the river and then we should have gotten
out of the river at one of those places
where there was like a little hut for
like fishing and hunting mmm that
sometimes people build on the river yeah
and then let the boat continue to go
down the river so they'll find the boat
miles down the river but they instantly
won't be able like I had I thought about
this for might at 35 minutes that we
died need to find the canoe it's like
it's broken up all the grounds yeah yeah
right we're just living living large and
some little catfish hut could have taken
off the jumpsuit or at least the sleeves
put him in the river
oh he that lost his arms his sleeves or
he's he's a dissolve throw this yeah you
got to throw some articles of clothing
so you were thinking all of this try to
go back to sleep
not wanting to think it but I was like
if I don't figure out the best way to
get away from the cops at the Gulf
prison I'm not gonna be able to get good
sleep and when I figured out I think
it's canoeing at night that was like
okay now I better sleep haven't thought
about a sense I don't think we ever
actually canoed at night did we of all
the canoeing that we did on the Cape
Fear River no I did a lot of I don't
recall any night lot of night fishing
night fishing and we did a lot of night
river crossing yeah
because sometimes we would get down
there too late or whatever it's
dangerous to be on a I mean you need to
have a spotlight I would think in order
to navigate any any rapids or whatever I
also wonder is there a I bet you there
is a golf prison somewhere in the world
and it's probably Sweden you know they
probably got isn't that where like the
really posh prisons are is that one of
the Scandinavian prisons they under or
nice Norwegian prison
prisons are nice our golf course is nice
and in Scandinavia why am I asking to
you I would think so why would they be
bad it's cold it's icy you can get snowy
up there but it's not always snowy like
under the snow there's a nice golf
prison it only it only opens in the
summer and then in the winter we send
the the prisoners to the to the ski
resort prison that's what they do
you know I don't know how it works but
if I'm going to ever kill somebody will
be in Scandinavia I I do think if I went
to prison and it our working relation
you would have to do all the thinking I
mean I'm not gonna sit I'm not gonna sit
in there like like the hurricane and
like try to figure out my own defense
you know and like yeah start writing
letters to see that two advocates who
can come in and get me out of just be
like me out of prison
well well this is just how it is man
don't worry so much about it
I've already started etching how many
days I'm here on my cell and I've
started way up here in the corner so I
don't want to run out of space like I'd
be thinking things like that right like
I did you know you know you got to think
strategically you don't want to start
etching the days on your cell like right
in the middle and then what are you
gonna do a spiral pattern no you got to
start in like the an upper right hand
corner I don't think they let you do
that anymore and also don't think is
necessary because I think you just asked
the guard what's the date and he just
tells you or you ask your caddy at the
prison that's like how many yards to my
release you know do I need a 3-iron to
get out of here that is that a thing at
3-iron it it were you would know nine
irons you know I wonder how it would
impact the presenter er there nine irons
well it just depends on what bag you're
in but yeah yeah nine iron is the
highest nine iron okay but then there
are stuff there Arthur as many as three
or four irons
of increasing loft above that that are
called like pitching wedge and sand
wedge and lob wedge and gap wedge and
things like that and there's some people
like my father and me by the way we
don't play with a 3-iron we play with
the three hybrid is for people who are a
little bit more help because it's hard
to hit those long irons these are the
kind of conversations I'm having
imprisoned by the way I'm well I'm gonna
teach I'm a gang leader I'm not gonna
lead in golf prison oh that's your
that's your in let's all get into the
prison and then you're sneaking over
there and digging a hole for me with a
3-iron I don't use it I don't use it a
cop always I mean I Christine I double
Chrissy and I got in a little kerfuffle
about you know in the wake of the the
earthquakes and we were talking about
the dynamic of like why she she's
gathering all this earthquake stuff and
ordering it and I was like she's baffled
by my by my just like I was acting in
golf prison just kind of um okay it'll
be fine if I ignore the fact I'm in golf
prison I think it'll be okay and I'm
like well you know what wait where does
that come from I don't know it's nice
it's a sure coping mechanism well and
there's I don't you know maybe there's I
don't know what the word is if this
codependency or if it's just laziness
but like when you were ordering all that
a pocket apocalypse stuff and I was like
hey you know can you just double your
order you graciously did and I felt good
about that it feels good knowing that
someone else is worrying about it and I
said Christie it's not that I don't
think it's valid is that I think that I
trust you I know that you're very
attuned to like the dangers associated
with it and being prepared as much as
possible so like I know I don't have to
worry about that I have this to a fault
I have this heightened sense of like
brain and like brain power allocation
and if I start allocating brain power to
like earthquake or apocalypse
preparedness that's less I've got to
allocate towards something else like
perfectly optimizing our vacation plans
so that was my response to Christie I
was like you got this girl and I got
this girl
so let's not I there's no implied
judgment here that I but I it does make
me look a little stupid it's like you
look pretty stupid in the dream yet well
I think it was the sleeves it was asleep
I didn't know they were taped do you say
you should have taped him I should have
just gone sleeveless because that's a
look that I think would work at Gulf
prison right you really assert yourself
has there ever been a golfer and I'm not
talking about in prison I think it's a
good sleeveless I think it's against a
dress code I got a dress code yeah you
think it off in tennis they need to keep
they need to loosen up you have your
shirt tucked in I don't know
basketball players have to tuck their
shirt in but I think that there's
something to do with like I think it's
just a safe disrespecting a game like
you don't have to wear role well you
know you don't it I think Tiger old
farts trying to seem like they well no I
think I don't necessarily think so I
think it's just it's a tradition but I
think you know Tiger wears that mock
turtleneck a lot of times like he has it
you know he wears red on Sunday and
that's pushing the limit and I I don't
recall specifically but my guess is is
that it must have been controversial
when he decided to not to wear that the
first time so it doesn't have a collar I
mean maybe there was a discussion about
the rules at that point I don't know
somebody looked that up his shirt
doesn't button and it creeps up to the
bottom of his Adam's apple it's almost a
turtleneck but it kind of feels like
it's like just pretending to be a
turtleneck let's call it a mock
turtleneck okay well that's not what
we're gonna talk about we're not gonna
talk about anymore about golf in
turtlenecks in prison or golf prison
we're gonna talk about whether or not
we're too nice and how that relates to
some personal things and also some
professional things but first we want to
let you know you think you can grab that
pin you think you can reach all the way
and grab that yeah you ready yep
this is the mythical society pin
separate curiosa s-- which second and
third two
members of the mythical society got when
they signed up we're making it available
to everyone in the mythical society I
didn't say I everyone everyone in the
mythical society at mythical dot store
but you're going to be at the mythical
store there's going to be more purchase
a code that you can wait I don't exactly
know how it is but if you're on the
society you will know how to get to the
listing at mythical dot store and then
how to buy it cool little pen you know
check out the mythical society you know
sign up I guarantee you'll love it well
that's what I guarantee if you don't you
can always quit it but I bet you that
won't happen that's your that's your
right though this pin is really cool and
we got other cool pins on the mythical
store that cotton candy Randy pen man I
I see some pictures of that thing it is
the legs gonna jump out and whispering
you hear it's a great design yeah
mythical nuts store are we too nice
I really don't have I really don't know
where this conversations where this
conversation is gonna go I maybe we can
tee it up with well it is true that we
do find ourselves asking that question
at times there's different ways to look
at this I'm gonna let you start anywhere
you want I'm just kind of set in the
table because I think that there's I get
I get our public persona like part of
our brand is that were nice guys but I'd
like to so we can explore that and it's
not like it's public it's yeah I do like
to believe that is private and then
obviously we can explore the the the
personal nature of yeah I I think we're
nice guys well my mo that cuz we're
southern is that just because that's for
other well what are the reasons right we
I think we talked at some point about
you know our conflict avoidance and how
that was sort of a deeply southern thing
I think some of it is related to that
for me the most interesting aspect of
this conversation is professionally
and how it relates to our content but I
do because it's so fresh I do and it's
it's very relevant I want to tell the
story that happened before my dream it
was probably the meal that I was
digesting when I had my dream okay which
is a Saturday night dinner with my
family now I've never taken my entire
family to VidCon and this was the first
time that that had happened fright they
came in a little bit late and it turns
out Locke had a couple of basketball
games in Anaheim that we had to stick
around for Owens I think I'd already
said this just told so many people now
I'm repeating things but so we spent
there from the night on Saturday night
and we were gonna go grab some dinner
and I was like we should do something
that's not like super close to VidCon
because they'll be like you know
there'll be a bunch of people from
VidCon not technically you're not even
really supposed to we're not supposed to
be out and about anywhere near VidCon
it's a security concern right so they
don't even let us do it and if you do
then you got yeah that's another night
where you have to be nice you have to
manufacture niceness for fans right and
because you're so mean in real life
which we'll get to later and so you know
that restaurant
Roy's there's like there's one in
Pasadena it's like a Hawaiian place
never heard of it I've seen it around
it's a chain that I think is not it
doesn't go outside of California maybe
he doesn't know but we were we wanted to
go there
a Hawaiian it's like a Hawaiian
steakhouse like I love like an upscale
Hawaiian restaurant okay so not like a
Hawaiian barbecue like strip mall
situation and okay let's go there and
didn't realize that it was actually very
close to the Convention Center like it
was far away from the hotel but it was
close to the convention center
and so I got a little bit nervous as we
were like pulling up but it was kind of
late I was like there might be a lot and
so then as we're driving kind of past
it's sort of like an outdoor mall kind
of area I do see a lot of lanyards and
I'm like this is kind of a VidCon crowd
and you know we had just done our
meet-and-greet and not that I don't have
a capacity I was actually just worried
about kind of violating the rules
honestly but I was also like the kids
have been here I haven't spent a lot of
time with them and I kind
want to just go have a nice dinner with
them so I told Jessie as we were like
pulling into the parking garage I was
like I'm gonna do the thing that we
talked about on this reading this
earlier hey Brown sterling Kate brown we
just call it the sterling K Brown that
that is the that is what it is right
it's and that is when if approached you
say I'm with my family I'm sorry like if
someone wants a picture somebody wants
an autograph or whatever you just say
I'm sorry I'm with my family and that's
a very difficult thing I don't know if
you've instituted that how many times
you've instituted that it's a very
difficult thing for me to do because I
am a nice guy right and I know also for
all the reasons that we talked about the
past like I feel a sense of obligation
to fans to to be nice and give them a
moment now so I go in but I'm like I'm
gonna hold to this guys I was like I'm
gonna do the sterling Kate brown we get
out of the and everybody's on board
family's on board seemingly at the time
mm-hmm
we get out of the car we go to the
elevator that is gonna go I got an
elevator no it was like there was a
parking deck and then it was like an
outdoor mall you got to go a parking
deck up and we're getting ready to get
on the elevator my dad has an elevator
in his beach house that's cool bragging
although in a woman houses on stilts a
mom and a little girl probably t12
immediate tests come up now I recognize
at least a mom but I think both of them
from the meet and greet they had just
been in a meeting Reed okay I have
thoughts but go ahead and but I kind of
didn't remember that until after they
went away I'll be to be honest with you
I'll cry I think they were the mean Bri
250 people it's night you can't remember
everybody I bet they remembered it so I
said she comes up and she's like I saw
them looking at me now slit here we go
little girl comes up and she's got a bag
and she's like can I would you please
sign this and when you say here we go
you're like here we go this is a test in
front of my family if I'm gonna sternly
Kate Brown
this moment yeah okay she has the bag
she says will you please sign this
what's the what's the family
configuration at this point because I
think that's important what it's for
people in my family I know the senior I
mean physically where they stand we're
all standing outside of an elevator
waiting for it to open
okay and I will say that no one else was
around okay
no one else was around but I'd literally
in the car not just 30 seconds ago said
I'm sterling K browning this situation
I'm not going off of that Lord girl says
can I can you will you please sign this
and I was like I'm sorry I'm with my
family okay okay okay she looks a little
upset little little shocked
including the mom but they but they're
but they were nice enough they're when
you say family they're okay and then
they kind of just went away but get on
the elevator she ever says dad that was
a little girl and then like and it looks
like yeah and nobody was around I'm
doing this for y'all are you gonna
criticize me hmm dang because if you
would have done it you got an elevator
and you imagined it playing out as you
return it hey it was a little girl
there was no one else around
right you know I got so close to doing
it but I was like this is the first test
and you know what and and what else did
and then what do they say well it
continued of course throughout the night
I just mean that the assessment of that
was at the end of that or did they say I
said you know what no no no I said you
know we're glad you did I feel bad I
probably should have called an audible
in that situation I don't know I got to
read the environment better no but
that's but that requires too much
thinking no no no no no look I was still
right I'm your boy I'm a nice guy your
boys too nice I think they didn't
articulate what they felt which was
prior
Tai's man that's the point and you know
what you did the right thing you did the
nice thing you were nice to those that
you love the most
for one when when we were walking the
floor at VidCon you asked if if I've
done the Sterling K Brown oh yeah yeah
yeah now I'll let you continue your
story I'm talking with Lilly because it
was the certainly capable thing happened
to Lilly and Christy you know it was
like me going up to him saying you know
my girls are big fans and then he's in
Dunedin easterly came Brown me and I
gained so much more respect for the guy
who already had so much for right so
Lilly Lilly experienced you know being
on the non receiving end of a sterling
Kate brown personally and then so and we
had had this discussion about this can
become a part of what I do yeah so we're
walking around the convention floor when
it's just for creators and their
families but with a lot of a lot of
creators and their families want to come
up to us yeah and get pictures taken
even in that environment and actually I
actually checked in with you as we were
going out into the and Lilly did first
and she as we're walking in she was like
dad or are you gonna you gonna tell him
you're gonna sterling keep around these
people just call it s kb s KBL
yeah and I was like I've already been
thinking about that yes because they
want to go to things they're like moving
and then they turn around and I'm back
taking a picture with somebody and it is
very frustrating it's like a perfect
place to SK be and she asked me about it
and I was like yeah I'm gonna do that
and then it it immediately happened and
I was like I'm here with my family and i
gestured and they were walking ahead so
it was like it was actually perfect you
see how you're holding me up right now
I'm trying to be well I can't even
physically be with them not like they're
standing there in an elevator thinking
that I'm the one making the mistake
right and it felt good and I also did it
I saw Lilly turn around and she heard me
say it and then I caught up with him and
there was just a little twinkle in the
eye nowhere
needed to be said and it was like okay
you know what my kids did not appreciate
me in the same way I think in their
heart they might I mean they may they
there's a little girl alright just go
back on it now no I'm not going back on
it and I will say that you kept doing it
okay in the restaurant in the restaurant
well on the way to the restaurant
somebody asked and I asked a bead them
and then in the restaurant there was a
family that was sitting there and you
could you could see it the discussion
began to happen it's like when are we
gonna go over there they waited until
the we are like our desserts had come or
whatever like we got through our meal
okay and I guess I did was just lost
heart by that point and they asked for
you know a picture and I was like okay
we can get a quick one I probably said
it in a very unenthusiastic way which
made that a pretty unenthusiastic at the
end of VidCon you're drained unlike any
oh I literally just done them all of
Saturday in in degree and then I you
know it does take week because we do try
to be there for people and be present
and some people have a story to tell
that maybe we don't want people to not
tell us something if they guys I'm gonna
say but it is it is unless you're a
robot it's an emotionally draining
experience and you're kind of just ready
to pull back from all that well it if I
may I suggest that we skip from fan
interactions to other types of niceties
because I thought you were when you talk
about roy's I thought you were actually
going to talk about the the most
quintessential nicety which is how was
your meal and I think that's another we
did a whole [ __ ] us we did a whole
podcast on that one so I don't want to
camp out there but I think I still
cannot say like toe the party line of
niceness and say because here here's the
deal the opposite of nice is not mean in
in this conversation the opposite of
nice is not being a
or being cold-hearted the opposite of
nice is what well sometimes honesty
honesty and you know it's it's so hard
to do it because it you just and I I
think if I'm totally honest if with
myself now about being honest with the
waiter it's like well you know the meal
wasn't that great I was disappointed in
the so-and-so it automatically it the
reason why I don't like doing it is
because it just makes you seem like an
entitled jerk kind of like talking about
how you got fans and you don't want to
be nice to well and that's the risk
right I we don't like talking and
sometimes and I'm sure we talked about
this when we talked about it but and
sometimes it's just not worth it
but you know I had this happen to me
when I was in North Carolina we had a
restaurant just Jesse and I and it was
one of the situations we were with went
it was a waterfront restaurant and we're
sitting there and then about 10 minutes
into all we had was drinks at the time
the waiter comes up and is like would
you guys like to move closer to the
water and again it's very difficult to
not take that as like is this because
they knew who I am or they're just being
nice to me and it's a problem you know
it turns out it was because the manager
was a fan that's how we got the table
upgrade but what's your point you were
you refused it no no I took it but then
the waitress asked me what what do you
want to drink like it's like a second
drink or whatever and I was like the
bars got mezcal right I was like I asked
for a mezcal sour which thanks to our
good friend Jaden he introduced me to
that drink I really liked it
it mezcals one of my favorite liquors
smoky and you can see on her face that
immediately she didn't really know
exactly what I was talking about maybe
hadn't heard that before
oh but she was like I think the
bartender will bill to figure something
out the bring me a drink long story
short I drank it the drink was really
not good at all and when she came back
and asked how's that drink I was like
you know oh you did it it's not great
you did it yeah man just listen to the
personal growth on this podcast but it
but here's the thing I felt like it hole
your face because really scrunched up
even when you retold it because I got in
a table upgrade yeah just take it what
take what you can get at this point man
but your thing is is that I kind of
wanted her to know that if somebody
orders this drink and you give them this
they an open happy what did she say and
she was like oh okay
I owe it a night but here's where the
nice guy came is I and you know I'll
probably drink it and I did I'll
probably drink it I kept drinking it
that's odd
I know me yeah that too nice well okay
this morning - nice my name is Denise my
name is Denise that's kind of the rhythm
of the song if I remember it correctly
yeah I'm doing the - nice stuff you
could do the D nice stuff head to Oberon
this morning yes I was texting you I was
like can I get a ride I was working out
man like nothing in my Apple watch
battery I'm looking I'm looking at I'm
looking at the bones like nothing like
you were texting Stevie like I was on a
thriller you and Steven you were texting
and then I'm on this other thread like
right below it and I'm like can I get
her out nothing and I'm like what what's
going on and then I'm like question
marks in I didn't you're like still
talking to Steve you weren't you talk
about being at the gym you you were
ghosting my ride text I didn't ever like
I actually do bird I didn't see any of
your text what I was doing is I would
check in in between like if I were in
golf prison I was working out and then I
had a shower and then you're gonna come
through from I never saw it until the
very end till I got through in my shower
you had Oberyn - yeah the cars were here
man
I hate I hate I hate riding in cars
where other people are driving because
I'm so much better at it and everybody I
just don't know why like I'm trying I'm
I'm sure I'll get into it later like
teaching Lily to drive so I'll leave
that out of this thank you that's a
whole other podcast but I just pride
myself on likes being a smooth driver
people don't know how to stop and go
they don't they really don't they don't
think they're you need to drive like
you've got an egg if you balancing on
the dashboard okay and that's how you
make an enjoyable ride the DMV should
sell those yeah you'd break the egg you
lose your license well you know what I
I'm gonna carry one around whenever I'm
in a car that's being sheltered you
break this egg I'll give you two stars
like an uber the uber egg yabber egg
yeah
uber should sell it or lift the lift egg
that just sounds like you're stealing an
egg though okay could be called the
rideshare egg we were riding in an uber
to the airport and I'm like if you're a
professional driver you should be able
to drive professionally I mean it you
should be good at it but nobody get
stuck into the details I can't that's
not stopping and going I get carsick
they don't ever no one teaches that and
no one is honest about it and I also I'm
a control freak yeah hey bro could you
learn to slow down more smoothly and
speed up and don't keep tapping your
brake every five seconds ago yeah did
you notice it was it was me and Stevie
and we were we were going for me we're
going to the airport and we never we
never talked about it but I don't know
if you noticed at one point in the
middle of our conversation we were like
he was like herky-jerky and us around
and I'm like I start like violently
gesturing with my hands like behind him
in the seat like just like I was so
angry because I was getting sick right I
don't are sick I just don't enjoy it but
I did you know and I was so close to
saying something like he was so friendly
when we got in the car he introduced
himself I was like you know what if I
would have remembered his name mmm then
I would I might say something now like
Raphael would you mind well we're not in
that big of a hurry so would you mind I
don't I couldn't formulate what I would
say but because I didn't know his name I
gave up
but let's say I didn't know his name I
still don't know what I would have said
that wasn't nice but still got my point
across which is hey man we're Raphael
we're how do you do this I don't know
Raphael we're not in a hurry and I'm I'm
prone to car sickness can you just you
know make it more about me and like my
shortcomings I'd say that would be
helpful
yeah I'm prone to car sickness and the
realtor not in a hurry turkey jerky
stopping and going is very troubling you
just stay in one lane and smooth it out
I mean change lanes if we need to get
into like go on a different road but
otherwise all this all this aggressive
stuff is it's not making me like you
more but you know it'd be a lot easier
if you're really hey Raphael here's an
egg
could you just yes yes and you know what
if the egg falls you get two stars I
mean in the hue be like got it you know
at that point this I think this love
this idea now it's not just a regular
egg and I realize that an egg is it will
roll off it's an egg that's sitting on a
little little a little pedestal pedestal
and then it it can Teeter off in any way
its natural state is to be balanced and
you know if there's a sudden stop but I
didn't say anything
yeah here's an even more pointed example
this morning on the uber almost sat in
the front seat but then it drastically
increases the chances that I have to
talk to the driver so I sat in the back
seat and I got carsick cuz the guy's
herky-jerky and all over the place like
busting the egg that I don't have
because that brilliant idea had not been
hatched but that wasn't the thing the
thing was where he's getting in the
carpool lane I was like oh this is good
we're passing a lot of people unlike the
I don't know the 134 or whatever that is
and then it's like we got to get on the
five but he's over here in the 134 and I
look at his GPS and I'm and you can get
out of the carpool lane it's got the
dotted lines like this is the
place that he needs to get over to get
to take my exit on to the thighs
can't wait too late and he's darting and
he's going so fast and I look at his GPS
and first of all he had a GPS and most
of them do but you'd be surprised how
many drivers never look at the GPS
because it's down on their lap or
something he had it mounted up there so
I could see it I'm like okay this guy's
I like this guy in it and it still said
134 so it was not telling him to get on
the 5 yet in the next few yards it
actually did change but by that point he
was he was trapped in the carpool lane
and could not legally exit it but I'm
seeing all this unfolding up where we're
back a couple of notches it's still
telling him stay on the in the carpool
lane or on the 134 I know he needs to
exit but I couldn't say anything just
like for the previous 10 minutes it was
hot as Hades in the backseat and I could
not bring myself to ask him to turn the
a/c up really I'm not noticing you do
that with a driver I've seen and I'm
having this internal dialogue of my
Gusman it's not worth it it's not worth
it
somehow me asking him to change the a/c
would be is not nice it's like it's you
know I'll blame you you've guilted me
into not putting my peculiarities on the
people but this oh well and then so I
couldn't even tell him to exit and then
he's like he's going straight and he's
trapped in the carpool lane I'm like
this is gonna add 15 to 20 minutes to my
ride and so I'm like um I really think
you need to get you need to take this
exit but there's no real way out of the
carpool lane he's like oh and at that
point the GPS changed just say he needed
to exit and he just broke the law and
just did it and I'm like good I'm so
glad he did that like even if he did
broke the egg at that point I would have
yeah giving him 5 stars but he's he's
like going over and I'm like
yeah you know the GPS is always late at
this point I'm totally lying
yeah I'm making this not true I'm
totally making this up yeah making it
feel good
yeah the GPS the only thing I've said to
the guy besides odd that was your exit
was then at yeah the GPS is always late
at this point and it's difficult because
you're trapped in the carpool lane yeah
and he's like What did he say he said
something weird and I was like is he
talking to me or himself it was like it
was basically like hey yeah I'm fine man
it was like that I'm fine man yeah I've
done this before and I don't need your
commentary yeah and I was like wow I was
trying not encouragement I think I you
know he was saying he didn't need what
he didn't need the emotional support
that you were offering yeah probably
didn't it's just I'm so it's just hard
to tell the driver what you want it's
like is he my driver at this moment like
hey you know what you should be in the
Farley I have so many opinions
you know I dunno and it's like but even
I even I am overridden with niceness at
that point to a fault well I had an exit
and stuff I I also a burden and I had
over to the gym in the nuber from the
gym to here and so I had two different
drivers this morning and driver number
one I sat in the front seat cuz he had a
very small car and I was like it's
sometimes in the backseat with me my
head will hit the ceiling
yeah most cars actually get to chin on
your knees and you know there was some
small talk about the weather and I was
like is this gonna turn into a
conversation and of course I'm hoping
not he brought up the weather because
you're in the front seat yeah no I'm
inviting this but I was told that the
app will now you can indicate on the app
if you want if you're a
conversationalist or not and I know I
said that I've never looked into that
you said you're not what the
conversation I I I was told that that
option is yes but I have not had only
doses so I ended up just kind of getting
on my phone and and then I started
thinking again I feel like if you look
at a pie chart of my brain activity at
this point you know at least 10%
sometimes revving up to 30 to 40% of my
brain activity is focused on what this
guy thinks of me and it isn't even in
the context of what his rating is gonna
be of me
it's literally like does this guy gonna
think I'm a jerk because I'm on my phone
the whole time or is he gonna think that
I'm like addicted to my phone like why
do I care and here even saying nice
things is not really about being nice as
much and maybe this is the key to
unlocking some new practice is the
realization that our niceties are much
more about us and about shaping
perception than it is about actually
being nice to somebody being kind to
someone I think a lot of it is just
rooted in ego yeah do i I think there is
there is a this very human thing to do
but I think that one of the reasons that
sometimes you may interpret an older
person as being blunt or not nice
sometimes they are just jerks but I
think in a lot of cases it's that they
have actually lost some of their ego as
they've gotten older which if you're
healthy I think is the direction that
you should be heading in that you're
getting less and less about yourself and
more and more about others as you get
older and so I do think that you know I
like to use the word candidness because
I do think that sometimes that's what it
is it's just like this person told me
what they thought just and again it's
not being super I do think that
sometimes being super particular about
things and then expecting everybody to
fall in line that can become an annoying
thing right but I don't think that's
what asking somebody to adjust the
temper
sure if you're hot in an uber is about I
think it's like what I kind of don't
want to be burning up back here and I
know that this person probably actually
does care about what temperature it is
some drivers ask you is it okay is it
okay back there
so it's not it's reasonable and not
jerky to say something about it but I
think that a big part of it is this like
reputation management with people that
you'll never see again which is weird
yeah but it's just this wanting so badly
to be liked and to not ruffle feathers
that you end up doing a disservice to
people and I and I do think that we earn
yourself because you're blazing up in
the backseat I think that's a term for
smoking weed and that's not what I mean
right yeah yeah but I think there's also
a button for that on the app my name is
Denise I'm gonna blaze up just be ready
I'm a conversationalist blazer I've
never thought about that but I have
thought about could I can I just bring
Jade in an uber this is just his tangent
but I was wondering that this morning
and again for niceness I was like I
would think so I don't want a negative
rating because this whole rating thing
is part of it too like it's a quantified
version of what we're talking about it's
like I'm gonna treat you in a way not
that I want to be treated or just
because you're another human and I want
to be nice to I want to treat you in a
way so that you will give me a good
rating that's messed up man
I literally think about my rating on
uber I have no clue what it is and I
don't think it has any bearing on
anything I don't know when it comes into
play I don't know when people can make a
come to a conclusion about it I don't
but she was just sitting in my lap she'd
be here right now I don't think it would
be a problem I guess there are some bird
maybe this maybe it may be all plenty of
people who'd have a problem with a dog
in their car maybe all right shear
operators have to be okay with dogs
maybe they indicate that somewhere on
the app maybe I don't know that's a good
question
because I mean especially with Jay it's
like Jade is not you know a giant dog if
you have a Great Dane or Satan
wouldn't even know she was there yeah so
I mean what about niceness when it comes
to content because you know the stuff
that we create that there are their
entire channels built on well of course
his entire channels built on drama I'm
not really I'm not talking about drama
as much as I don't know I guess this is
this is like a bordering territory to it
that I'll just call hot the hot takes
man you know you've got an opinion on
something and you've you know so much
and it's not just digital content but
like radio for years television all
types of talk content is so we can talk
about it as it relates to ear biscuits
is successful because it's just it's hot
takes it's it's opinions it's I mean and
a lot of times is there's a lot of there
could be like some it's supercharged
with some vitriol some anger some some
bitterness some just like complaints
like the opposite of being nice being
brutally honest or just having a punchy
opinion and that's not we maybe we
started to do a little bit of that but
not really I I think that when we on
your biscuits we we kind of we resist
the urge to like give our unfettered
opinions on things because I do you
think there's a niceness component there
what what's going on there are we too
nice when it comes to our content well I
think there's I think that I think
that's part of it I think it's really
complex because I do think that there is
just something about our personalities
naturally whether its niceness or
however you would want to describe it
that we don't tend to be we're both
opinionated for sure
but when it comes to the types of
opinions and hot takes that would be the
kind of thing that would people would
care about on the internet that
not really a natural part of our
dialogue we don't spend a lot of time
thinking and talking about those things
but I also think that because we were so
focused on just making people laugh and
for a number of reasons and we'll
probably do a podcast on this at some
point like why we approached our content
the way we did in the early days and
like why you know why it started so
family-friendly like more
family-friendly than it is now still
generally family-friendly but it was
like squeaky clean g-rated from the very
beginning yeah I think you attract a
certain audience it's like oh these guys
are gonna do something that never
offends people and it's just all about
being light-hearted and then when you
build a fan base around that you've kind
of cornered yourself a little bit
whereas you know and one of the things
that Harley from Epic Meal Time said
probably at this table was that you kind
of get what you give to your audience
you get back what you give and he gives
his tone especially at the time was very
like harsh towards his audience and you
kind of attract people who like that
kind of thing and you kind of give it
back so I think that we've we've
actually developed a pretty nice
community because the content isn't
vitriolic in any way and that's and
we're proud of that that's that is the
product that's a good thing me saying
that right now is like oh I don't want
to I don't want it I don't want it to
seem like I'm being critical of our of
our core audience or an aspect of our a
contingent of our honest taste well okay
well here's where I think that here's a
perfect example of because I'm not being
critical where I think that the audience
that we cultivated and how nice they
were in our for the most part
created a content problem for us and
that is with our local commercials right
we've talked about this a number of yeah
that's a good case study we've met we've
never really been into prank content per
se we did that one
video or we've done a number of like all
of our men on the street video yeah they
were were there kind of prank inspired
and they're kind of make people feel
awkward it they're based on making
normal people feel a little bit out of
sorts and getting some laughs at their
expense yeah not in a super
mean-spirited way but for some people
anything in that realm is mean-spirited
and the nature of the local commercials
that we made back in the day and then on
commercial Kings which is still back in
the day this is a long time ago of
course we used real businesses and real
people from those businesses and the
thing that we found so funny is when we
put normal people into these situations
these ridiculous sort of structures that
we created for them and they just did
their thing you're kind of laughing at
slash with them and everybody ends up
being happy and it's good for business
and people or people love the result but
one of the reasons not a clear-cut a lot
of people are uncomfortable with it is
because a really really strict
interpretation of it is that your hat
you're laughing at these people you're
having fun and humor at their expense
and some people are not comfortable with
that at all
so now we are both very comfortable with
that it's a little bit of a generational
thing I do think that the younger
generation is much less comfortable with
it although I will say that even though
I didn't encourage this like my kids are
much like I was at their age like some
people can't watch that this show that
we talked about on Impractical Jokers
some people can't watch that because
they're like I don't just don't like to
see anybody be made to feel
uncomfortable they love it yeah they
think it's great
but we ended up stopping doing those
commercials because we just ended up
getting one of the reasons was we just
ended up getting so much pushback people
would be like this doesn't seem like
this isn't the the stuff that I like you
guys for this just seems a little bit
mean means spirit and so we just were
like okay well it's not like we have to
keep doing this we did a bunch of it we
can move on to something else
yeah I saw I do think that that is an
example of our niceness in general and
especially in things like GMM
cultivating an audience that then
couldn't really take the non nice
content yeah and I was talking to Aaron
from game grumps and he was he was
talking about as their talk show which
you know is inspired format wise by good
mythical morning the 10-minute power
hour which were big fans of and he was
talking about how he said yeah it's you
know he was talking about the g m'm
influence on on how they created that
but he was like but you know we've got
the tone is a little different cuz we
got a bit more of that fu energy like
you guys don't really have like fu
energy and I was saying something about
their reddit contingent yeah and and he
was like you know the people that
respond to that are the people who then
they'll like f you in the comments but
then when we looked at how much merch we
were selling we they had a whole they
have a whole reddit thread that them or
none of their crew has anything to do
with because it's it's just all the fans
who just hate on them but he said that a
remarkable percentage of course I don't
remember the number because I don't I
don't have mental capacity to remember
other people's numbers right you
thinking about your vacation he said
that it was a big contingent of merch
sales or from those people who were like
constantly fu fu because they're like
they're very invested and their fans you
know it's just a different get what you
give and it's you know I I'm a little
envious of of that energy because I
don't know it from a comedic standpoint
it seems I don't I don't know what the
word is it just seems more emphatic
comedic ly emphatic you know when you're
when you're doing something that can be
is edgy or is so quite literally edgy so
it pushes you either one way or the
other
mmm alright it's it's easy to
subconsciously feel like that's a more
legit
form of comedy because it's sending you
in one of two directions either love or
hate versus just like like I think when
we're you know our tone it's very
welcoming so it's like you can also oh I
can tolerate it you know it's like where
someone maybe left and we end and I
think that we end up compensating for it
a little bit because again if we were
just completely ourselves throw caution
to the wind we would be more offensive
than we are I mean if we if we were if
there was no guard up at all as to what
is a more broadly appealing welcoming
sort of tone it would be a more caustic
tone it just would be of course we have
more opinions than we share yeah anyway
and also know that people are gonna say
they want more of that well and you
might think that oh well that we're
talking to might they say well that
would come well I can see that coming
from rep but from link know the reality
is it will come from it would come from
both of it I don't to speak from for you
hey no yeah it's not just a thing that
comes from the bitter tall one but you
know interestingly you're kind of you're
also kind of talking about you know cop
like stand-up comedy as an example the
purest form of comedy right which we've
never really I mean we'd do it kind of
but we haven't done like traditional
stand-up and definitely not alone I
thought farts with a purist form of
comedy go ahead are you saying it
because my seat just made a farting
noise no just making a joke the the
whole give and take that you have with
an audience and the fact that if you're
going to speak up at to a comedian he or
she is going to rip you a new one and
that's part of the Act heckling and then
responding to hecklers is part of being
a great stand-up and a certain type of
stand-up though I I don't think that
eyes Austin well well no no even even
though the nicest comedian like a Brian
Regan even the nicest comedian a gaffer
he's not going Gaffigan okay
is not I guarantee you that when he does
his life stand-up and somebody heckles
him that he gets the best of them Oh
because you can't exist now how
mean-spirited is it you know
it's even like when we kind of do that
when on tour
yeah we don't do anything that's like
ridiculously you know vindictive or
whatever but if you if you're if you're
gonna have the courage to speak up at
our tour we're gonna you know doing
something that's gonna make you make
people laugh at you and in it but it's
all in good fun I do
I definitely not want to get into a
place where we're not willing to just
like light ribbing is no longer allowed
but but how I think the question is is
like how does it work its way into the
content what are we afraid of and you
know how do you navigate it because just
another quick data point is when we were
guests on the h lee podcast big fans of
ethan and ela and their growing family
of sons and dogs or they got one of each
you know it's like it's hot take Central
over there it's in it's it's extremely
entertaining like it's it's it's it's
hot takes for the sake of entertainment
like that's why I enjoy it it's almost
like taking a position just for the
laughs a lot of time not all the time so
and so being on there was like its but I
you know I I think when it comes to the
type of things they talk about you're
more informed and more opinionated about
those specific things so that felt like
more of an outlet for you to be there
then it did for me but it I think there
were other things that would that would
get me going
probably germs or you know but um or
herky-jerky
uber drivers but the type of stuff they
talked about was something that like I
mean we don't go into that stuff on our
podcast Smosh does some of that on their
podcast because it is a it is a great
way to to develop a fanbase if that's
something if that's the way you're
interested in talking about things but
it's it's an it i I don't you tell me
what you think I don't think that's a
place where what we've we've made
decision that that's not what that's not
it's not a place that we go you know and
I'm not talking about YouTube drama as
much as like current event hot take type
stuff where it's you you you cannot be
nice
you cannot come across as nice that's
not that's not part of the equation in
those conversations well I feel like
trying to incorporate drama or
commentary about controversial things
into what we're currently doing would be
a little bit of a betrayal and I because
I feel like there's so much of that
right now because we're now just out
we're not just throwing what we create
into into a vacuum like we it is
experience in the greater context of
internet and entertainment in general
and we are so polarized right now right
so I is is opinionated as I am and as
bitter as I can be about some things I
do think there's something to be said
for the fact that our show and our
content in general is something people
can come together over around people of
differing backgrounds people of
differing political opinions you should
be able to come to our show and be like
this is something that we can agree on
and I do think there's power in that
some people call it a cop-out some
people say you're doing that just so you
can make more money and have a broadly
appealing product I actually personally
and I think we both think I speak for
both of us but I know that that's
something that I care about is I don't
like the disunity in our world and in
our country it's needed now more than
ever and I think that something that
brings us together and I do think that
we have we're kind of special especially
equipped to kind of bring people
together you know we understand multiple
perspectives
you know having embodied multiple
multiple perspectives over the course of
our lives and I think that that puts us
in a position to be like hey it's not
you all these people aren't bad and all
these people are bad it's like hate like
there's something like let's have a
dialog there are some things that we can
agree on
now we don't end up talking directly
about those things very often but so I
do think it would be a little bit of
disservice to be like all of a sudden
we're gonna be talking about all this
stuff and we're gonna be throwing our
opinions out there and you know blasting
people who disagree like that's just not
the spirit of what we do but I do think
the thing that the one of the reasons
that like what Ethan and you do is
appealing or what game grumps does is
appealing is because it's more fun to
just let your guard down
it's more fun to just be honest and be
like I don't really care about the
impact of the consequences because I'm
just being myself to have a little
filter in a guard on everything you say
it's a little bit tiresome so I do think
that as you get older and I think this
is one of the reason that there's there
is more innuendo as an example in all of
our content now than there was when we
started is because you know what when we
talk privately there is a lot of
innuendo like that we just I we both
find sexual innuendo to be very funny
and we use a lot of it in our normal
private lives so we also did when we
were in seven we've always done it do
you remember in the very beginning but
we haven't done it in our content right
and until it's just you you 1,500 1,600
episodes you just become a little bit
more yourself and I think that there's
something freeing about that and that's
a place I think the sexual innuendo is a
place where we've without we talked
about it some and we still continue to
talk about the the ways that we the
lines the the ways that we will
incorporate innuendo and the ways we
want so we know what like what our best
practices are to use the corporate term
but in an effort to conclude this
conversation I I think that it's I need
to have a prolonged thought we've got
time
yeah in an effort to come to a
conclusion I think that we can we I feel
good with the summary that you've given
of hey we're trying to create things in
conversations where it can it can be an
outlet for for anybody that simple well
I would say that that's a principle that
applies to our content we don't want to
be a you know a dividing force we don't
want to be a polarizing force in the
world because there's enough of that
already that doesn't mean that there are
some things that we consider to be
non-political but just human issues that
need to be addressed that we will take a
stand on and talk about and that's at
our discretion as we see fit but I think
that as time goes by we will continue to
be more and more ourselves yeah I I
think it is yeah the balancing point
just to piggyback on that is yeah we're
good we're not gonna be fake we're not
gonna be nice and lie lie through our
teeth just to be nice yeah you know
where I want to I want to be nice when I
actually mean what I'm saying I don't
want to say anything here that I do not
mean so I think and that's why we that's
why we choose our topics conversation
and and I think that you know I've seen
you see you see the chatter and the
speculation sometimes when people are
trying to figure out like what you know
what things lead to the evolution of the
show over time or the the way we talk
and I think one of the things one of the
accusations that can be levied sometimes
is that
oh you guys are continuing to push the
boundaries because you want your content
to be more accepted or you're you're
you're doing this to get more attention
or to get people to care about you and I
think that well the reality is is that
we've kind of always talked this way
but the longer we do it the more the
layers get pulled back and you see who
we are and I personally that's something
that I mean I mean I've been focusing on
this personally a lot just through
therapy honestly it's just like
getting out of my head getting into my
heart living more from a place of
feeling because I've done enough
thinking I've done a lot of thinking and
I think part of that is continuing to
kind of let go of what people think
about you continuing to have your ego
hopefully continue to be drained as you
get older and I think just a natural
result of that is that you're just gonna
be more of yourself and so the things
that we do aren't a result of trying to
be provocative or trying to get more
views we're always gonna be trying to
get more views with just what you know
we're trying to be successful but it's
really us being more of ourselves and I
think that ultimately to tie it back to
the original question it's that we're
not as nice as you think we are if you
thought we were really nice yeah I mean
and that's a broad word but I think that
if some of there is a core niceness that
as long that which we're striving to be
nice as long as it's true to who we to
ourselves yeah
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you think join in on the conversation
Rex in effect I'll give a music rec been
listening to Bahamas I don't think I've
wrecked Bahamas I think we've talked
about it personally because I'm like we
used to really be in a Jack Johnson that
like laid back you talked about Roy and
his Hawaiian vibe with his elevator yeah
elevator goes slow would you listening
to some Jack Johnson back in a day
Bahamas is kind of like my updated Jack
Johnson and the specific song that I'm
gonna recommend a
is got a turn a turn my I gotta take it
out of airport mode
I know it's airplane mode off the album
Bahamas is a fee I think that's the
guy's first name a F ie
all the times a good song but stronger
than that you start listening that song
and it sounds like islands in the stream
Kenny Rogers Dolly Parton duo duet and
then I mean you think he's just gonna
start singing like like Kenny Rogers but
then he doesn't are they from the
Bahamas he sings like Bahamas this one
guy is he from the Bahamas no I think he
just channels that vibe okay I can't say
but uh if you like that vibe check it
out especially that song yes thanks for
sticking with us for listening to this
conversation that we didn't know where
it was gonna go but it went where it
went and it'll continue to go where it's
gonna go but it's not gonna go anywhere
next week or for the next three weeks
because we were taking a little break
we'll be back on August 19th August 19th
we'll be back from our epic vacations
we'll be talking you about those until
then hash tag your biscuits to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]